Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
When we sync of European
colonization of the Americas,
we tend to think of the big nations it
did so the ones which had large lasting
colonies, England, France,
Spain, Portugal, the Dutch,
and even Russia to some extent.
However,
we often forget to discuss Sweden and a
discussion when Sweden did in fact whole
colonial territory in North
America territory in fact
that for many Americans is
much closer to home than they realize,
but why? What was it like there?
Where did these Swedish colonies go?
And this video,
we're going to answer all those
questions and more as we discussed,
Sweden's colonization
out of North America.
The year is 1638 Sweden is in the
middle of the 30 years of war,
but it's only beginning.
It's rain as an empire,
an empire forged by the recently
to cease King Gustavus Adolphus.
The Swedes don't merely intend to turn
their nation into a regional power.
The challenge nearby nations such
as Russia, Denmark, and Poland,
they have goals to challenge the rest of
Europe as well and competes on a global
scale. Was France, England,
and Spain who are busy beginning of
decolonization of distant lands like these
nations. Sweden under Queen Christina
will attempt to colonized North America.
The project was first
envisioned 12 years earlier,
mainly by its founder of Flemish
man named villain was links,
one of the founders of the Dutch
west India company as well.
Villain links was a businessman and a
Protestant and saw an opportunity to
spread both business and
Protestantism and the new world.
Disappointed with the activities
of the Dutch west India company.
He would turn his business interest
to an opportunity he saw in Sweden.
He acquired permission from King Gustavos
Adolphus to found a trading company
known as a Swedish south company.
The main focus of this company would be
trading the resources of the new world,
such as primarily for and
tobacco accordingly plants
and set up a colony to do
so.
We're ranged to govern this colony.
Ousel links recruited the
help of another Dutchman,
the former governor of the colony
of new Netherland. In fact,
patron mean we painter had been replaced
as governor of new Netherland following
a dispute involving illegal first rate.
Accordingly,
now jobless and with experience
trading in a new world.
He was the perfect man for the job.
In 1637 and expedition of
two shifts was organized.
This collaboration between these
individuals and other Dutch businessmen,
the Swedish government and businessmen
from places like the holy Roman Empire
set off for the new world.
The following year. In March,
they landed in an area that is now the
present city of Wilmington, Delaware,
considerably south from where
a few centuries earlier,
the ancestral relatives of the Swedish,
the Icelandic and Greenlandic vikings
had landed when they discovered the new
world.
The men surveyed the land and eventually
selected a location along the Delaware
River,
which they believed would be easy to
defend from attacks from native Americans
or the Dutch or the English
who had ambiguous claims.
The same area they called the and the
subsequent settlements for Christina after
the reigning monarch at the time.
Some of them are always first actions
where the whole negotiations with a nearby
native American tribes,
namely Volvo,
not pay and the Susko Hanuk after
establishing trading agreements,
land agreements as well as other
diplomatic terms for these tribes.
The Swedish helps secure the position
on the continent and left their main
threat as a Dutch who were
settled in nearby territory.
The north mainly in the modern
day state and city of New York.
Fortunately for the Swedish or the Dutch,
currently lacks sufficient
manpower for a major battle.
Having accomplished many of the
preparations for the call Neiman,
we returned to Sweden to bring a second
load of colonists. This settlement,
unfortunately on this
voyage while stopping in the
Caribbean to purchase goods
to bring back to Europe to
help pay for the voyage.
He was caught in a hurricane and
parish there. Five years later,
he was succeeded by a man
named Johan Bjornsen, prince,
a Swedish soldier and mercenary
weighing somewhere around 400 pounds.
The native Americans would refer to
him as big belly. He and the settlers,
he brought over what continued to maintain
amicable relations with the natives
of the area.
Prince would establish Fort Naya
Elfsborg and Fortune Naya Guttenberg,
thereby expanding the settlement and
securing a Swedish defenses against a
potential Dutch English
or native invasions,
though forced Naya Elfsborg nicknamed
Fort Mosquito was eventually abandoned
mainly because of the surplus
number of the bogs in the area.
That's a time the defenses
were mainly precautionary.
The Swedish were concerned
a potential attack,
but the settlers coming
mainly from Sweden, Finland,
and other parts of the Swedish empire
as well as Netherlands, Denmark,
and Germany who would eventually number
around 600 coexisted mostly peacefully
with their native Dutch and English
neighbors at first with time, however,
tensions would strain. The Swedish
would eventually support the Susko.
Hancock's in a war against England and
land disputes continued with a Dutch.
The settlers of new Sweden were
of a variety of backgrounds.
They were craftsmen,
farmers, mercenary soldiers, businessmen,
Lutheran ministers who can it to
first Lutheran Church in the Americas,
et cetera. They brought with
them a building technique,
which was common in Finland and
Sweden at the time log cabins.
The usefulness of these structures was
quickly adopted by colonists from the
Netherlands and England and other places
as well who are not as familiar with
the structure log cabins of course remain
with us to to stay in varying forms
all originating with a
Swedish and Finnish sellers.
Prince was an effective leader of new
Sweden and contributed a great deal to its
efficiency and prosperity.
However,
he ruled with what many of the colonists
felt was too much power and to petition
began to replace him,
which was successful in 1653 and 1654 he
was replaced by Johan class and rising
one of risings first actions.
Upon arriving in new Sweden as governor
was to front the now hostile dush wet
erected a fort called
Fort Chasm here nearby.
He took this forward without firing a
single shot as a Dutch lacked any gum
powder with wish to defend themselves.
The Swedish rename the fort to Fort
Trinity fearing a response rising then
ordered the defenses of porkers
sooner to be strengthened.
Ricing was correct in his fears and 1655
as the second northern war erupted in
Europe and southern Dutch and
Swedish on opposite sides.
The governor of the Dutch colonies haters,
stripe is sont laid siege to for
Christina with seven ships and over 300
soldiers,
outgunned and outnumbered.
The Swedish eventually decided
to surrender for Christina
to the Dutch which the
victors would rename to Fort Altina
with a Swedish military busy defending
Europe.
Reinforcements from the homeland were
entirely unlikely and indeed never came.
Sweden's colonization
attempts in North America,
though at first prosperous unfortunately
failed within a few decades with the
loss of fork.
Christina,
the Dutch were not exactly cruel
to Swedish settlers that remained.
It was demanded that they submit and
become Dutch subjects, but those refused.
We're merely returned to Europe. Those
who stayed were allowed some autonomy.
They were allowed to
form their own militia,
continue trading as they had continued
to practice their religion and speak
their languages. I of course,
mostly Swedish and Finnish
and retain their lands.
Some sellers from the Swedish empire
continued to come to new Sweden. Fact,
this subjugated Swedish colony continued
officially until the Dutch colonies
were in turn annex by the English and
in 1681 when William Penn receipt as
charter for Pennsylvania where new Sweden
overlapped, the colonists remained.
They're assimilating and the societies,
I will continue to emerge in the states
of Delaware and New Jersey, New York, etc.
However,
very few modern day Americans of Swedish
and Finnish descent artists Senate from
these original colonists.
The vast majority came as immigrants to
the United States in the 19th century.
Though new Sweden was
not exactly successful,
its foundation and presence
are significant and a
greater story of European
colonization of the Americas. Sweden with
later hold other overseas territories,
even in the Americas,
the Caribbean to be precise,
but its hopes to expand its empire
outside its regional boundaries were
unfortunately lost, perhaps primarily
with this story, the support,
the creation of more videos like these,
a link to that channels patriotic
can be found in the description.
For more videos like this and videos
on many other subjects be should have
checked out the rest of fire of learning
and subscribe. Thank you for watching.